the College Board has announced that its
revised SAT tests will now give students
a victimhood score we will examine how
grievance became the left's most prized
currency and why the new SAT is bad news
for everybody then a 23rd confirmed
candidate enters the 2020 Democrat race
for president and this one may be the
worst of them all
then I will respond to abortion law
criticisms from right-wingers some have
been directed at me personally and
finally the mailbag on Michal Knowles
and this is the Michal Knowles show
[Music]
so much to get to today obviously we've
been covering abortion all week because
of these laws there are now more laws
Missouri's state Senate has just passed
a highly restrictive abortion law a
heartbeat bill I told you that was going
to happen after I met with the Missouri
state senators last week now it has
Louisiana is about to pass one the
governor of Alabama who is a woman just
signed that heartbeat law it is all
happening right now this is the pro-life
moment as Ernest Hemingway described
going bankrupt things happen gradually
and then suddenly the pro-life movement
has been gradual now it is suddenly all
happening so we will get to that later I
want to talk about this SAT scandal
because the the college cheating scandal
has gone mainstream then we got to get
to Bill DeBlasio but first let me tell
you how good I feel not just because of
all the great news we've had this week I
feel good because I feel safe I feel
secure and part of that is because of
wise company if things go wrong and you
got to get out of Dodge and you can't
rely on all the modern niceties that we
have it's important to make sure that
you and your family are protected wise
company takes an innovative approach in
providing dependable simple and
affordable freeze-dried food for
emergency preparedness and outdoor use
this is important too by the way not
just for when the zombie apocalypse hits
but for natural disasters as well I live
in Southern California they keep telling
us every five months they say the big
earthquake is about to happen we're due
for the big one we're 50 years overdue
it can be a natural disaster and at
least I feel that I sweet little ELISA
my family are safe wise company meals
are designed to protect your most
valuable asset your family when
government resources are strained it can
be days if not weeks before you can get
fresh food and water and you can't rely
on someone else you have to rely on
yourself you know this I mean you know a
lot about personal responsibility you
can't know what tomorrow may bring but
you can have peace of mind knowing that
you'll be ready with all you need don't
put yourself in a situation where you
need something and you don't have it and
you can't get it all the ingredients
from wise company our chef prepared
internally by wise company why is
emergency food is an investment in peace
of mind for your family and that's the
big thing here it's the food is great I
mean it's it's really good high-quality
food but it's just that peace of mind
you it's just one thing you don't have
to worry about do it now
forget about it and when you need it
thankfully you will have it this week my
listeners get any wise emergency or
outdoor food product at an extra 25% off
the lowest marked price at Weis food
storage calm when entering Knowles
Canada wles at checkout or by calling
eight five five four five three two nine
four five plus shipping is free Wise has
a 90 day no questions asked return
policy there's no risk in taking the
initiative to get yourself and your
family more prepared today do it and
forget about it until you need it that's
wise food storage com promo code Knowles
Canada wles
to get any wise emergency or outdoor
food product and an extra at 25% off and
free shipping be responsible make the
right choice and have some peace of mind
the college cheating scandal is going
mainstream you remember a few months ago
Aunt Becky and a few other celebrities
were caught cheating their kids way into
college and they would cheat a few
different ways they would cheat by
pretending there were student athletes
they would bribe coaches and they would
also cheat on the SAT they would they
would cheat on the standardized test
score to try to get their kids into
college now
the College Board itself the
organization that administers the SAT is
setting up a system to cheat on the SAT
it's the only way to describe it the big
takeaway is here the left is trying to
turn victimhood a grievance suffering
into an objective measurable currency
you know they've been talking about
victimhood now increasingly for at least
the last ten years in in major parts of
their conversation and their political
advocacy now this is intersectionality
going mainstream and frankly if this
goes through if this is accepted by
colleges and by society broadly I don't
know how we come back from this I don't
know how we take a step back so so the
question I guess is will it work and
then the question is what does it
actually do what does it mean so what
the college board is going to do
is a sign an adversity score to every
student to try to capture their
socio-economic background ideas like
this have been floated for a while they
say don't take into account affirmative
action don't take into account race or
sex or something like that take into
account socioeconomic status and the
College Board now wants to make this
part of the SAT so it will include the
crime rate and poverty levels from a
student's high school and neighborhood
and it actually will not factor in race
there are already other ways for the
colleges to get that sort of information
the students will not be told their
scores but the colleges will see the
scores also probably not a great idea
there obviously seems to be some room
for abuse there what if a student gets a
score that he disagrees with he has no
recourse he doesn't know what the
college board is doing and the college
board won't say how it calculates the
score this is what they say they say
quote there are a number of amazing
students who've scored less on the SAT
but have accomplished more we can't sit
on our hands and ignore the disparities
of wealth reflected in the SAT they've
accomplished more according to whom I
don't know but they score less than the
SAT and so now it's up to the SAT to fix
it now look they might be right the
students might score lower on the SAT
but actually accomplish more in their
lives sure the question is why would you
then factor that in to their score on
the SAT this isn't the first time
they've tried this the college board
tried this two decades ago
same kind of thing put in a grievance
victimhood measurement and the college's
roundly rejected that in the 90s but are
they going to reject it now this is a
very different time in 2019 than in 1999
culture is very different and we have
this obsession with a victimhood so it I
don't think the colleges are gonna stop
it now the colleges are being run by
maniacs the worst people at these
colleges or the administrators the
administrators who protest Andrew Klavan
the students don't protest Andrew Clavin
at Stanford University the
administrators do it's the
administrators who smear me is some kind
of bigot because I say men aren't women
at the University of missouri-kansas
city that was the Chancellor of the
university wasn't the student
organizing some massive protest some
students but it's the administrators who
were doing it so just a little personal
anecdote on this because this this
really bothers me people people get the
question of college admissions so wrong
elite people get just do not understand
what it's like to grow up with
relatively not that much money and they
think they do and they're very
condescending about it they're very
elitist and they just don't get it they
make a whole slew of assumptions just a
little personal anecdote I grew up in
more modest socio-economic circumstances
then I think all of my friends I also
scored higher on the SAT than all of my
friends and I'm very glad that I didn't
have an adversity score on my SAT to
help me out I didn't have any grievance
score I don't know what I would have
gotten on the grievance score but I'm
very pleased that I didn't because the
the adversity score puts a little
asterisk on your college admissions it
would have diminished the accomplishment
of getting into college and also it
would destroy the academic confidence of
any students who rely on it I mean this
is the problem with affirmative action
Clarence Thomas hated affirmative action
Clarence Thomas one of the most
brilliant guys in the country he's on
the Supreme Court is maybe the best
jurist on the Supreme Court he despised
his experience at Yale Law School he got
into the best law school in the country
and then when he went to get a job he
realized that the employers assumed he
only got in because of affirmative
action he didn't get him because of
affirmative action he got in because
he's extraordinarily intelligent and
hardworking but that little asterisk
destroyed his achievement and there's no
way to come back from them so this score
this adversity score is it's gonna be
out of a hundred fifty is going to be
the average and if you get higher than
50 you are a victim and if you get lower
than 50 you're privileged you don't know
how you're gonna come up with that this
is exactly the backwards approach this
is exactly the wrong approach so
I'm not saying that the question of of
socio-economic difficulty is not a
serious question there is a problem that
this is trying to address the problem
this is trying to address is generally
speaking rich kids have an advantage in
life I mean they have an advantage in
most things and this includes getting
into colleges we all know that that is
the case so okay if that's a problem you
want to equalize things and you want to
level everybody okay what are the
current solutions that we have we
already have some solutions for that
there are scholarships so people who
come from more modest socio-economic
circumstances can go to school for not
very much money or for free that's what
happened to me I had to pay very little
money to go to college and I'm very
grateful for that
I'm glad that that program exists you
don't need an adversity score in your
SAT for that to happen
what's another way that we solve this
problem one way that they try to solve
it is race-based affirmative action
that's the idea I mean the assumption
with race-based affirmative action is
that black people are at a disadvantage
mostly because of money I guess there's
there's systemic racism that is claimed
by the left but also it's just a matter
of black people as a demographic group
have less money than white people as a
demographic group so what they're so
when they talk about race-based
affirmative action what they're really
trying to talk about often is
socio-economic circumstances so okay now
you're trying to get more specific with
this new program and fair enough the
race-based affirmative action often
doesn't work because it doesn't factor
in wealth so a lot of times you'll have
people getting into good schools or jobs
or whatever who are actually just
immigrants from Africa or the children
of immigrants from Africa they're not
the descendants of American slaves the
purpose of affirmative action ostensibly
is to get rid of the
legacy of slavery in the United States
but if that's the case why would you
then give that preference to a recent
immigrant from a wealthy part of an
African nation that doesn't make a lot
of sense okay there are some problems
with that what else do we have to
address this problem we
have programs at the school level right
at the universities that it's not like
the universities are unaware of
socio-economic disparities the
universities all have programs to go
into other states to go into certain
neighborhoods to go into certain towns
to go into certain schools that are
disadvantaged the admissions offices
already take all of that into account
that's why school send admissions
officers to all sorts of different
states if they just wanted to get the
highest SAT scores they wouldn't have to
send students into all of those states
and they and they then would get
students from disproportionately small
pockets of wealth in the country ok so
you've already taken that into account
the reason this is so awful is the
entire purpose of standardized testing
is that it's standardized if you if you
take standardized testing and you stop
standardizing it there's no purpose you
might as well get rid of the SAT but
Michael you might say surely things
matter beyond the SAT yeah of course
they do we already take that into
consideration schools take into account
athletes and athletes get preferential
treatment
legacies get preferential treatment
children a big donors get preferential
treatment favored racial groups favored
racial minorities get preferential
treatment we yes we already take a lot
of people who will get grades right your
grades your GPA is not standardized
across every school in the country some
students have grades above a 4.0 I don't
know how they do that but because some
schools give extra credit or something
ok so that's not you already have all of
that you already take into account
socioeconomic status a lot of the time
also there is a standardized measurement
that different schools take into account
to different degrees and what this would
do is get rid of that standardized
movement altogether it wants to take
away standardized measurement now the
last standardized measurement that we
have is becoming arbitrary and the
reason that this is so pointless and
actually damaging is you can't measure
suffering you can't measure grievance
you can't measure adversity objectively
you can't do it there there are a lot of
poor kids who grew up with both of their
parents and who were told to study all
the time and who then worked their way
into good high schools and good colleges
this is obviously the case among a
recent Asian immigrants and the children
of Asian immigrants in New York City in
particular now they're trying to fix
this in New York they say there are too
many Asians at the magnet high schools
they come from very modest
socio-economic circumstances there are
plenty of those people there are also
rich kids say so let's say you have a
rich kid right and he's comes from very
high up socio-economic circumstances and
then his parent dies when he's 15 and
he's got to work through that in high
school and he works through that and he
takes the SAT and then he's dinged
because he hasn't gone through adversity
I think that kids gone through a lot of
adversity he's going through more
adversity than most kids are gonna face
how do you measure that how do you put
that on the test how about even if you
took your stereotypical rich kid your
stereotypical you know his drug get his
gets a brand new car when he's 16 and he
never has to get a summer job and he's
just a total rich kid right and he
develops a drug addiction by 15 or 16
I've seen this happen
I grew up in a pretty wealthy county so
this happened a lot and he develops a
drug addiction in his life is spiraling
and then he turns it around he cleans up
he Sobers up
he works hard by the time he's 17 18 and
he's ready to go to college that guy
certainly overcame a lot of adversity
now he kind of foisted it on himself he
made some bad choices when he was a
young teenager but then he made it
through that adversity he clearly
improved his life that kid went through
more adversity than the poor kid who
grew up in a good household with two
parents that he always made the right
choices how do you measure adversity and
and why is adversity the main measure
you can't measure adversity in that way
because all people suffer everybody
suffers the left wants to convince you
that only certain people suffer only
their favored groups suffer and
everybody else doesn't suffer at all
well guess
what the rain falls on the just and the
unjust alike
now not everybody talks about their
suffering because it's unseemly to talk
about your suffering all the time it's
so ugly it's not manly it's not mature
it's for its whiny to complain all the
time it's ungrateful it's impolite it's
not good it's also completely incoherent
this this whole measure victimhood thing
doesn't make any sense
think about why we're even talking about
a victim put in the first place why is
the left focused on grievance and
victimhood for the last 20 years the
main reason I think is because you can't
measure it so the right comes in we say
look there are these objective
measurements and this guy's getting what
he deserves and you're getting what you
deserve
and and what the left comes out they
says you don't know my pain you can't
possibly know my lived experience stop
trying to use your oppressive logic and
your oppressive facts to to erase my
experience of the world I am suffering
and the only reality that I know is my
suffering and you can't know that
because it's subjective also now its
objective and you can measure it when
it's convenient for me that doesn't you
can't have that both ways either her
suffering is is subjective and I can't
know your experience and so we are where
we are or it is objective and I can tell
you know you're not actually suffering
that much no you actually haven't gone
through that much adversary' adversity
you can't have it both ways either you
can measure it or you can the left wants
to have it both ways right now and I
think we just need to point out to them
everybody suffers I mean this is there's
a great line in a play by I think it's
by Tennessee Williams called Orpheus
descending isn't I think that's the play
and it's anyway it's this guy this kind
of vagabond he's walking around and he
he wants to stay at a lady's house for
the night he's trying to sweet-talk her
and say come on let me stay at your
house and she goes nope you get out of
here he says come on I have nowhere to
go and she says everybody's got a
problem and that's yours everybody's got
a problem and your problem is your
problem and his problem is his problem
but if we start
to measure this if we make this the
be-all and end-all of society first of
all we're gonna get into a very ugly
culture because we'll just all we'll be
doing is talking about suffering and
complaining and everything's wrong all
the time it's going to incentivize
people to suffer more and it's any of
this going to deny their very real
suffering of certain people it's so
wrong it's so arbitrary and it's
perfectly to be expected with what the
left has given us for the last 20 years
on some brighter news we are in the
pro-life moment right now it is
happening pro-life since roe v-- wade
the pro-life movement has proceeded
gradually now it's happening suddenly
all at once Missouri just passed a major
abortion law that will restrict a will
outlaw abortion after eight weeks after
a heartbeat it would be detected so it's
actually not even reliant on a doctor
detecting it we know that at eight weeks
the heartbeat does exist there's a law
in Louisiana that is about to go into
effect it's about to be passed we had
the governor female governor of Alabama
yesterday signed that law this is
terrific news and yet some longtime
right-wingers are not happy about it
this puzzles me I think this moment this
pro-life moment is it's it's finally
real you know it's very easy for
everybody to talk and so I'm pro-life
ya know I'm Pro okay sure I'm pro-life
now it's real and so it's gonna separate
the pro-life wheat from the pro-life
chaff and here is even I mean just just
to show you how widespread this is even
Pat Robertson about as hardcore as it
gets about as pro-life as it gets about
as conservative as it gets he's getting
this wrong and he's questioning these
laws I think now Obama has gone too far
they've passed a law that would give a
99 year prison sentence to people who
commit abortion there's no exception for
rape or incest it's an extreme law and
that they want to challenge Roe versus
Wade but my humble view is that this is
not the case we want to bring to the
Supreme Court because I think this one
who Lou
okay that's his argument pat robertson
pat robertson about as hardcore as it
gets pat robertson the man who said
the feminist agenda is not about equal
rights for women it is about a socialist
anti-family political movement that
encourages women to leave their husbands
kill their children practice witchcraft
destroy capitalism and become lesbians
that guy he says this law is too extreme
he's not alone he's not the only one
who's saying it's too extreme the
publisher of the new reboot of human
events Human Events is an old
conservative magazine it went out of
business and then this year a couple
guys restarted it rebooted it the the
publisher of that new reboot criticized
specifically me and Matt Walsh for
defending these laws not just defending
them for celebrating these laws and I
think a lot of conservatives are having
these ideas they don't I don't think
they really quite have arguments here
but they do have feelings and so I think
we should address those feelings because
I get it I understand where those
feelings come from I just don't think
they hold up to the rigor of logic so
let's take a look at their arguments and
see if they've got any point I really
did I really wanted to do and I couldn't
I couldn't deal with it like I normally
do not like sticking my finger in the
eye of the pro-life movement which I see
is a core part of our coalition and I
have deep sympathy for the perspective
but like I can't let this stuff go the
things that Michael J Knowles and Matt
Walsh are justifying today appalled me
like very very deeply like the things
the way they're deciding to argue this
position it strikes me is so
unbelievably flippant and incoherent and
ridiculous
that it just needs to be called out like
in general there's a way to be pro-life
without making arguments that are just
disgusting I don't I mean it like these
arguments genuinely disgust me and I'll
try and explain why why I think they're
so flippant and they're so dismissive of
concerns about bodily autonomy and and
essentially any sort of idea that you
have a liberty interest in your own body
they were so so flipping that they just
appalled me okay so this goes on for
like four or five minutes you'll notice
he's talking and he's saying it's
disgusting
and it's awful and these terrible and
you'll notice he's not making any
arguments he's just sort of venting his
emotions
you'll notice too at the beginning he
says the arguments he's making the
things he's saying the the content of
what Knowles is arguing is awful and
disgusting and the way in which he's
arguing them is awfully so he switches
at first it's the actual thing itself
what is my argument I'm saying we
shouldn't kill babies went before there
weren't that's my that's the beginning
and the end of my argument
don't kill babies in the womb as it
that's the whole content so he's saying
that I disagree with that appalls me
that's disgusting and then he's saying
the way in which he's arguing it is also
disgusting and so on that latter point
he might be saying I'm being flippant or
glib or something I actually don't think
I have been I certainly can be but I
don't think I have been on this topic
itself he doesn't give an example
obviously in that part of the rant so I
can't I just can't judge it but he's
also saying that the argument that we
shouldn't kill babies in the womb is
appalling to him but why does he is he
go on and say this thing goes on for
half an hour I listen to I haven't even
listened to the whole end of it is that
I didn't have that much time but I did
listen to the parts where I at least
found that he was addressing my
arguments in particular so here's what
he takes issue with specifically so
Michael Knowles basically has been
trying to defend the law and which
imposes these enormous punishments on
doctors who commits abortion and but do
not punish the women who are who get the
abortions right it says and this is one
tweet quote abortionist Alabama face
potentially harsher punishments than
rapists because murder is considered a
more serious crime than even than rape
and says also that Alabama has starfrit
flaws and then he says and then then
somebody asked them it's like okay but
if that's true he says if it's murder
why shouldn't the woman be punished if
at least it's a conspiracy to commit
premeditated murder and Nola says quote
and this this blows my mind because
conservatives why egor justice are
compassionate and conscious of human
frailty I'm sorry you just said abortion
was worse than rape we don't look at
whether or not our compassion and
consciousness of human frailty does not
lead us to not punish rapists right okay
there
factual things wrong with what he said I
actually didn't say that murder is worse
than rape I said that murder is
considered by our society by every one
of our states in the whole country and
the whole civilization murder is
considered worse than rape and therefore
it follows that people who commit murder
will be punished more harshly than
people who commit rape I then also point
out that Alabama has some of the
toughest rape laws in the country
coincidentally I'm all for making the
rape laws much worse I'm I'm perfectly
fine with capital punishment for rapists
I have no problem at all with killing
rapists
i I totally I mean I I would support
that if I were the king I would kill
rapists once we convict them I would
kill them I'm not the king I understand
why our laws don't do that but those are
totally separate issues the crime of
rape and the crime of murder the crime
of abortion now he goes on to say he
acknowledges my answer to the question
well if abortionist is morally
equivalent to murder
why don't we punish the women and the
reason we don't punish the women is
because conservatives while eager for
justice or compassionate and we are
conscious of human frailty so he says
haha I've got you there
because if abortion is murder then you
should punish the women no we shouldn't
abortion is different than killing
somebody out on the street it is morally
similar if not morally equivalent but it
is circumstantially quite different
obviously and and the the motivations
that would compel a woman to try to
procure an abortion the personal
motivations the cultural motivations and
because the Supreme Court invented a
fictitious right to abortion what we now
consider the legal conditions that would
lead her to do that are different and so
because we are taking all of those
circumstances into account we recognize
that we probably shouldn't punish those
women there is there is a difference in
the motivation to commit that crime
there is probably not however a moral
difference in the crime itself if I kill
baby of one-day-old does anyone really
believe that's morally different than
killing a baby two days before he's born
no of course not nobody really believes
that this guy will Chamberlain the the
editor of the nur that publisher of the
new Human Events I don't think he
believes that how about three months
before the baby's born is it was it
really morally different you're killing
a baby you're a baby with unique DNA who
is its own person the the fact of
killing that innocent human being is not
different however there are different
circumstances that lead to that crime I
acknowledge those historical cultural
and today legal differences and so it
seems much it seems perfectly defensible
to punish the doctor who is a an outside
force who is committed who is actually
committing the act who is actually
killing the baby who does is not
compelled by all of those various
circumstances and it makes perfect sense
to punish him according to the law but
to not punish the woman I don't see any
reason why that why that shouldn't be
the case I know it's not neat and clean
it's not it doesn't have that perfect
ideological clarity right all shallows
are clear and and will Chamberlain
acknowledges as I do that the
circumstances that lead one to shoot
some guy in the street and that lead a
woman to get an abortion or different
and so I'm saying we can treat those
people differently according to the law
perfectly fine while still defending the
victims of those crimes who are the
victims of exactly the same crime
they're being killed they're innocent
and they're being wrongly killed now
will gives up the whole story in in this
last bit he explains the the real issue
that he has with my argument and I think
it shows you why these squishy
pro-lifers the people who are pro-life
but don't but don't want to actually
have real pro-life laws why they go
wrong we'll get to that in a second but
first remember to tune in today for my
latest episode of the conversation at
7:00 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific where
I'll be answering all of your burning
questions the episode is free to watch
on Facebook and YouTube but only
subscribers can ask the quest
subscribe and tune in today 7 p.m.
Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific join the
conversation
go to daily wire.com right now so much
more to get to we have to talk about the
23rd Democrat in the race all of that at
daily wire.com 10 bucks a month hundred
dollars for an annual membership you get
me you get the end were Clavin show you
get the Ben Shapiro show you get the
Matt wall show you get the conversation
and you get to ask questions and that
you get to ask questions backstage you
get another Kingdom you get so much
stuff you get the leftist here's tumblr
sea to shining sea we're protecting the
unborn and the left is furious get your
tumblr before you drown we'll be right
back with a lot more
so before we get to the 23rd Democrat in
the race and before we get to the
mailbag I just want to finish up this
point because the will Chamberlain the
publisher of the new Human Events he he
does explain his his big issue and this
I think is the central question of
pro-life here's here is what I think is
essentially why he's so upset and
offended and appalled by the arguments
that Matt Walsh and I and other pro
lifers are making the issue I have of
the way than Michael Knowles and Matt
Walsh try and think about the ethical
questions with regard to abortion is
they're extremely deontological meaning
that they are like entirely like trying
to logically reason their way through
semantic arguments to the idea that it
is never okay under any circumstances to
allow abortion to be legal even in the
most extreme cases sure you're right
you're right wait so dant ology for for
those who are not familiar with that
word is the moral concept of considering
a moral act in and of itself not not
considering the consequences of some act
not saying well this act is right or
wrong because of what it will lead to
which is called consequentialism but
saying this act is right or wrong in and
of itself it's it's wrong to kill an
innocent baby that's making that claim
to him is taking is being to Dejan
tallada chol and then he uses the word
logical he says what what knowles is
doing is he's starting with the premise
that it's it's wrong to kill innocent
babies and then he's semantically by the
way the word semantics means meaning so
in the meaning of what that is he's
following it logically to the conclusion
that we should not have legal abortion
right that's what I'm doing I'm
considering the act of abortion itself
then I am following it logically to its
conclusion and I'm saying we should not
have legal abortion right and what he's
saying is stop thinking so logically
about this is it's bad to make women
give birth to the babies they have it's
bad not to let people kill babies in the
womb okay
that's not an argument but I do I do see
the impulse for that what he's saying is
the extremes are so wrong but Pat
Robertson is saying is the extremes
they're not going to win most Americans
aren't on the extremes okay fine I'm
with you
oh you're right two-thirds of Americans
don't want to overturn roe v-- wade I
understand that political reality and so
with these guys the kind of the moderate
guys the incrementalist guys the
gradualist guys what they say is we
shouldn't follow the logic of abortion
to its logical conclusion which by the
way the the people who are seriously
thinking about this now on both sides of
it are following abortion to its logical
conclusion
New York's Governor Andrew Cuomo
Virginia's governor Ralph North and they
are following abortion to its logical
conclusion if it's okay to kill innocent
babies then we shouldn't not be able to
kill them after 26 weeks we should be
able to kill them as they're being born
or right after they're born okay yeah
that's that is the logical conclusion of
abortion if you support abortion the
logical conclusion of abortion if you
don't is a baby as a baby you shouldn't
kill babies who are innocent so
therefore you shouldn't kill them at 26
weeks you shouldn't kill them at 20
weeks you shouldn't kill them at 6 weeks
you shouldn't kill them because their
babies doesn't matter their
circumstances doesn't matter who the
mother is who the father is you
shouldn't kill babies and there are hard
cases that come out of that hard cases
make bad law fortunately the hard cases
that everybody is citing right now cases
of a baby being conceived because of
rape or incest or that pose a threat to
the life of the mother that accounts for
less than 1% of abortion so it's it's
very disingenuous for people to bring
that up also these laws make an
exception when the life of the mother is
at risk so even the argument that will
is making on that point just is not the
case however I see it I get that they
people want a middle way here
politically okay fine if you want a
middle way there are two options you can
either pick some arbitrary point and
pretend that the Constitution allows you
to kill babies before a certain point
but not after a certain point and I
don't know you're gonna have to look
really deep into the Constitution to
find that arbitrary point in there
that's one version of finding a middle
way the other version is
let the states make their own abortion
laws the Constitution says nothing about
abortion it isn't one way or the other
it is not in there let the states make
their own laws so New Yorkers can live
the way they want to live
Alabama's can live the way that they
want to live and hopefully as has been
happening over the last 50 years people
will see the moral reality of abortion
and then they will change their laws
because they're not hamstrung by some
ridiculous
Supreme Court decision that invents a
right to abortion they can actually
change as their moral clarity changes
which will change in New York that's
what should happen some conservatives
are disapproving of these laws because
they say they go too far oh I don't know
if the Supreme Court will go for it
oh maybe we should water it down maybe
give me a break
guys fight the fight fight the fight if
you're not gonna fight the fight what
are you doing well maybe we should pass
laws that won't try to overturn roe v
wade but they'll just chip away at roe v
wade no guys fight the fight we actually
when I I got to meet Antonin Scalia
twice before he died and one time that I
was meeting him some of us asked what
about story decisis what about story
decisis is the legal principle that that
gives weight to precedent so we've got
Roe vs. Wade
1973 then we've got Planned Parenthood v
Casey in 1992 both uphold the imaginary
right to abortion so what about that
precedent and I support taking precedent
into account I think what these
conservatives are saying is think about
the precedent think about the president
some decisions are so egregious this is
what Scalia said some decisions are so
egregious that they simply have to be
overturned Dred Scott decided that black
people couldn't be US citizens that was
a Supreme Court decision
there's no incremental ISM there there's
no way to chip away and change it
gradually over time either black people
can be citizens or they can't be
citizens you have to overturn that
decision either the Constitution gives
you a right to kill babies or it doesn't
give you our right to kill babies
there's no incremental ISM there there's
no gradual change fight the fight before
we get to the mailbag we have a 23rd
Democrat running
were president now and because he's my
old mayor Mayor Bill DeBlasio in New
York we've got to talk about it because
bill de blasio is launching his campaign
on a pro theft agenda there's plenty of
money in this world there's plenty of
money in this country it's just in the
wrong hands here in New York City a
place that is legendarily tough and
being and complicated good thing about
New Yorkers is they look the same
whether they're really pissed off at you
or they like you
we built an agenda that puts working
families first we had to fight all over
the city
all over the state to make sure that
people got a decent wage we are raising
the wage to $15 an hour waitresses and
dishwashers and store clerks and people
are working small manufacturing firms a
backbone of New York City you will have
the legal guarantee for the first time
of paid sick leave this has never
existed anywhere else in this country
fully comprehensive guaranteed health
care my wife Charlene and I believe
health care is a human right it has to
be available for all it has to be
affordable and it has to need mental
health services okay first of all the
only guy who needs mental health
services in this entire video is Bill
DeBlasio I just would like to point out
being a New Yorker myself I'm in New
York all the time I've lived in New York
for a long time Bill DeBlasio is a
terrible mayor and he's extremely
unpopular not just among conservatives
there were only about 20 conservatives
in New York anyway but among liberals
too they hate this guy he has made the
city worse he's made it dirtier he has
made it more crime ridden he's it's just
bad the homeless problem has gotten out
of control he's a very bad administrator
the Democrats were gonna try to
challenge him last election they weren't
able to get their stuff together but
he's not popular in New York so I think
he's thinking I got to get out of New
York I got a run for the big office now
is my shot because there's no clear
front-runner the other thing we know
from this is just as the whole election
is shaping up this is going to be the
free stuff primary
all he's talking about is giving stuff
away for free except he's taking it to a
little bit of that tougher extreme he
said New Yorkers are tough if we don't
like you or we like you we have the same
look on her face which is basically true
and so he's taking the the free stuff
primary to that tougher level and he's
saying we're gonna steal stuff from
people he's actually turning it not just
into the free stuff primary he's turning
it into the theft primary he said
there's a lot of money in New York
problem is it's in the wrong hands he's
saying your money is in your hands and
therefore it's in the wrong hands the
money you've earned is in your hands but
it's in the wrong hands therefore well
who's whose hands does my money belong
in de Blasio says my money belongs in
somebody else's hands okay oh I want
bill de blasio to tell me whose hands my
money belongs to he's not gonna speak in
those kind of terms I also want to point
out he's not a real New Yorker he's a
Boston Red Sox fan and he's got an
Italian last name but he's not Italian I
think it was a stepfathers name or
something like that
so we just I just as a New Yorker as an
as a descendant of Italian heritage I
just want to say please don't blame him
on us we don't even like him New Yorkers
do not like this guy okay let's get to
the mailbag the reason we're gonna cut
the mailbag a little short today because
we got the conversation later on but
let's get to as many questions as we can
from John Michael with respect to
Alabama's and Georgia's new abortion
laws I haven't seen any coverage related
to in vitro fertilization my
understanding of IVF is that many eggs
are harvested and fertilized at once and
at times many embryos are implanted and
in the uterus some of which are removed
how should laws be crafted with respect
to aspects of IVF thanks John PS thanks
for taking my question last year
regarding coping with my wife's multiple
miscarriages as an update we kept open
to the possibility of new life in our
marriage and our happily awaiting or new
son this summer congratulations that's
great news I'm very glad to hear that
yes nobody talks about IVF and now IVF
is coming up because the left is
throwing this in the pro-life movement
space they're saying wait a second
you're saying that it's a it's a murder
to kill an unborn baby
but IVF can very frequently
creates many embryo fertilized embryos
it creates many new human beings and
then it freezes them away or it implants
them in the uterus and then if you don't
want to carry all those kids it it takes
them away it aborts them see this is a
contradiction fair enough yeah IVF in
the way that it is usually practiced
fertilizing multiple embryos and then
freezing or destroying them is not
defensible I this is something the
pro-life movement doesn't talk about
because there's some disagreement or or
it just would create divisions but
nevertheless it is the case I mean from
a prudent political matter right now
we're talking about abortion laws and
we're having so much great effect on
that so I think we need to keep pushing
until that goes to the Supreme Court and
overturns Roe versus Wade however it's
also the case that IVF as it is usually
practiced is is not defensible from a
pro-life position from Derrick hi
Michael
the claim that making abortion illegal
will only decrease the number of safe
abortions rather than abortion in
general is all over social media can you
please speak to any evidence that
supports or negates this Thanks
absolutely I can before Roe vs. Wade in
1970 there were 52 abortions in the
United States per 1,000 live births
after Roe vs. Wade the year after that
1974 that number jumped up to 242
abortions per 1000 live births by the
80s it reached its high of three hundred
and sixty-four abortions per 1,000 live
births Roe vs. Wade
caused the abortion rate in the United
States to skyrocket not just the legal
abortion rate the total abortion rate to
skyrocket in the United States and as we
discussed before the year before Roe vs.
Wade was decided 39 women died from
illegal abortions 24 women died from
legal abortions and when you factor in
the legality of abortion throughout the
United States you find out that
proportionally it was just as dangerous
to have an illegal abortion at that time
as it was to have a legal abortion that
is those are the facts we you can look
at the statistics from the CDC abortions
skyrocketed after Roe vs. Wade
from Landon dear mr. Noles I'm a
Christian and recently started a wedding
DJ business and I had the thought what
should I do if I'm asked to perform any
same-sex wedding what do you think
thanks Landon what are you views on
marriage I know that certain Christian
denominations or sects now approve of
same-sex marriage or the redefinition of
marriage so if you're in one of those I
guess it doesn't prove a problem to your
faith if however you say that marriage
has a meaning and that meaning does not
include monogamous same-sex unions but
it does it or any other version of that
that marriage is between a man and a
woman if you believe in the traditional
definition of marriage yeah I guess it
would be pretty hard to participate in
that marriage I suppose it depends
though if it's a gay couple that is not
get it having a marriage they're just
having a party and they say yeah we
don't we don't agree I mean I have many
gay friends who do not agree with the
logic of redefining marriage they say no
marriage has a meaning and I have a life
partner or I have a special friend or I
have a whatever but that is not the same
thing as marriage so if they're having a
party which they explicitly say this is
not a marriage this is not a wedding
that I guess that gives you some leeway
but this is a very difficult question
that is changing daily because marriage
continues to be redefined every single
day if you had talked eight eight years
ago people had civil unions a civil
union the same thing as a marriage I
don't know that's another question it
would people refer the New York Times
said when they were talking about
etiquette on how to refer to a gay a gay
man's gay husband had newcomb husband or
this and they suggested the word partner
now probably that term is is big in it
probably now your your politically
correct supposed to say husband or
something I don't know it's changing
every day and you you will have to
answer that question as regards your
faith if however you believe that
marriage has a meaning and if the the
clients are saying this is a gay wedding
this is a marriage this is a wedding and
and you don't want to participate in
that you shouldn't participate in them
from Evan
dear Michael the man who loads European
football that's me it's called soccer
last night on ladder with Crowder's
Stephen said he once considered creating
a company baseball team he implied that
ladder with grad er would play against
the daily wire I know that baseball is
your favorite sport with the daily wire
except if the challenge was ever made
and what would the starting lineup be
have a swarthy day Evan no I would never
accept that I played Little League for
eight years I think I hit the ball four
times no chance man I actually I should
point out I didn't hit the ball very
much but I did lean into pitches like
Don Baylor
so I on-base percentage was very high
but know also by the way virtually
everybody in the political media is like
5 10 5 9 somewhere around there steven
crowder is a giant man
so no uh-uh no thank you I'll play a
ping pong with him or something all
right we have a lot more questions but
unfortunately we we do not have time to
get to them we'll get to them on the
conversation today so be sure to watch
it live and ask your questions in the
meantime I'm Michael nose this is the
Michael and old show I will see you on
Monday
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Jeshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 today on the
Ben Shapiro show controversy continues
to swirl around Alabama's new abortion
laws that's today on the bench Pierrot
show